hey guys it's just stayed and guess what
we are making another Animal Crossing
video it's been a while I've had so many
requests to do this I actually did
record a house makeover video but I
never ended up posting it so I'm gonna
use that to reference my next video of
when I show you my updated house I've
been wanting to do an updated video but
every time I go to do the video like
it's not ready it's not ready and now
it's really not ready because I
completely just destroyed this entrance
and redid everything I'm looking for
like weird things to put here hi I just
went to Emily's Island and she made me
these lamps and then I customized them
and then she sent me this little Pisces
lamp which is really cool I just got the
Taurus tub so what I'm really on the
hunt for is like cool lights like this
like neon light up stuff I've been
buying all of these floor lights that I
can every day is but I can only send
myself so many per day it's just the
struggle is super real garan Animal
Crossing New Horizons
but I wanted to have like a little entry
that had like a bridge I tried to do a
diagonal one but it didn't work as I
already had these buildings here so I
wouldn't be able to make it happen
unless I moved them and I didn't really
want to move any buildings I'm just kind
of leaving everything the way that it
was when I started the only building
that I've moved so far is over here and
it's my museum and I moved it back maybe
like five spaces just so that it would
match up with my lovely little plaza
here
we got a little tea set over here that's
some pretty colored flowers I've also
been planting weeds because they make
such a nice little decoration but then
when they grow too big I just pull them
and then we plant them it's so
unbelievably time-consuming I don't know
what I'm doing with my life anymore but
it was a matter oh these I still need to
customize Oh
hello star fragments I would take you
Jenna had a meteor shower on her island
last night these I'm gonna all either
custom color whites or pink or something
I'm not sure I haven't decided yet this
is this is a new little addition here my
little beach area this I wish was real
in real life
smoothies if I should put my to the
slingshot oh I got a few little clover
patterns here
that I really like a lot I also haven't
picked my fruit in several days because
I want everything to be grown so that I
can pick it all at the same time because
it's been driving me absolutely insane
this game is sucking away any of my
actual real life that I have left so
this is what I do I'll just pick it I
plant it so it's a nice small little
beady-eyed oh gosh what am i doing I
don't know got some my favorite little
fossils here this is a little DIY
section because I'm always needing it
wasn't to do some crafting this is new
Sean just gave me this this morning and
I am obsessed I've got a little Plaza
here I'm probably gonna put something
here but I haven't decided what yet I
want to collect all of the different
types of plans
outside here this is the turnip section
this is a sad reminder of what happens
when you don't sell your turnips you
define a 600 turnips l still need to hit
all my rocks is busy today setting a
chance to do all my learning tasks Oh
star fragment thank you this is my
orchard and it is unbelievably obnoxious
to harvest this fruit because I put
everything so close together that you
can't even see where the fruit is so I
have to like do some camera movements to
see if I got all the fruits it's
normally I don't this up coming over
here is on my favorite little spot but
I'm not gonna take you this way yet kind
of like a secret little hidden gem Oh
fossil up there mushroom I hate
mushrooms
I hate mushroom so much that every time
I get a mushroom DIY it makes me lock
the roll up I haven't made us a single
mushroom DIY yet because they're so
gross I mean if you like mushrooms
whatever I just do not we're gonna go
over here this is one of my favorite
views I love it I want to get the I
think it's like a big moon I wanted to
put a big moon up there but I couldn't
find one and I don't have the DIY for it
yet either so if anybody does have a DIY
I will happily take that off of your
other pans this is my fossil swap area
which is why I do not have a five star
Island because I have not picked up any
of the stuff but I've been a nice
resource for my friends
swap some bottles nice little throwback
small radio let's change the music this
year just some more fruit trees also
incredibly obnoxious to try to harvest
because guess what you can't see
anything
Ian now that this pathway is a custom
design so it's not one that's built in
every single time I hit a button I'll
end up kicking up the design it's just
another process I've wasted so much time
trying to not have seams and I don't
even care anymore
why I'm gonna do care I'm trying to not
care I am currently trying to kick out
Tammy because she's gonna just she
followed me around the island I wonder
if she's home I don't I got her house
because then it might show her that I'm
interested in her and I am absolutely
not look one of my favorite Islanders is
Knox and he I think is a murderer so I
put a fridge or freezer outside of his
house just in case you run a book the
bodies or something I'm whatever his
pastime is that oh I'm not sure
I just I'm gonna make sure that he had
of what he needed to get the job done
cause I don't oh he's a piano now
[Music]
my gosh his tanks birthday remind me
that tomorrow is tanks birthday okay you
get him a gift
see that girl talented I am he knocks
give me that piano I want a piano my
golden casket he's a murderer
he keeps the bodies in his casket it's
been confirmed
I am very thank you let's go back out
and continue this tour I gave him that
little butterfly too and he just keeps
it there like as prized possession I
thought he was gonna eat it cuz that's
just the kind of animal he is like his
little light he's kidding me he's not
too much happening on the beach area
here do you have some coconuts probably
I'm going to harvest right after this
video I just wanted to look really nice
for you guys I'm also really upset
because when I show you guys the secret
juice this little secret area a bridge
was supposed to be built today but I
forgot that I owed like ninety bells and
I never went back to pay it off last
night
I guess I'll pick up some seashells
because why not let's swap area if
anybody wants to come grab some DIYs or
some items that I don't want which I'm
gonna just sell all this stuff because
it's also hurting my Island ranking like
I'm so sucker for at the lighthouse
which is that scariness night and up
there to the left
is in my flower breeding grounds which
doesn't seem to be we're doing that well
because I need to have people come over
and water them for me and I hate asking
my friends come over do two asks like
hey I know you're probably busy of not
doing anything but you can over water
hours I love meringue she's one of my
favorites I love halfway up here so this
takes you into my secret garden area
which is not only a secret at all and my
three very sad black roses and I don't
have a golden watering can yet so I
couldn't even go to gold roses but I'm
very proud of this this took however
many days I've been playing the game
these are the ones that I'm trying the
hardest to breed this is overflow I
don't really care about these but
they're all just here so I have them all
just kind of catalogued so if anybody
else needs some flowers they're here
this is where the breeding grounds
happen so every morning I will come in
here and scoop up the ones that have
been bred and then disperse them
throughout the island which I still need
to do when I still need water yes today
it took me a long time to get the green
mom that's way too long it's got roses
this took me way too long to do like I
can't even I mean weeks because I kept
rearranging flowers weren't matching up
properly and I just couldn't sleep at
night I would just be thinking about my
flower arrangements this I may also once
read came to town so I had to like dig
out this whole backside I dug all this
out so that I could have a nice pathway
down to one you know
our art dealer is here and where is he
oh he's not here he's never here what a
tease it's like hey fill up your Museum
oh yeah but then he comes like once
every two weeks okay this is where I put
a bunch of extra watering cans so if I
can force my friends to come over and
water
they just nice enough to at least give
him a watering can and I'm gonna have an
incline actually I'm not sure I've
decided yet I don't think I'm gonna do
one here because you can just go around
this back side and this is the incline
that was not completed yet but I need to
take you through the secret way to get
here because it's my favorite it's
really really cool I enjoy it it took
way too long I think I said I ever liked
until 3 a.m. so this is the little
secret area here which is not a secret
at all because there's a path so you go
through the fossils and take you to the
money tree that I need to you can hit
that here it is this is my little
entryway into basically nothing because
there's there's nothing over here really
I was gonna put like some cool like
gifts or something years but if anybody
came to visit of me they found this area
they can get some stuff but I wanted it
to be kind of like an isolate an actual
area I do want to get some cool lights
to put here but these are the ramps so
you'll go up here and then this ramp
will take you up there and right now
there's not really much up there I was
thinking about making a coffee shop or
something haven't quite figured it out
but there will be another ramp here so
in three days
that'll be here I do like that I can
just use this to walk all the way around
to the other side of the island
booth I still haven't done all my tasks
yet today but this is this is a problem
I actually have real work today
so I wasn't able to spend all day
wasting my life playing this game I mean
this is my life now oh are you where's
your fruit where's your fruit I have
written those all I think I need to have
fruit on everything or I can't shake
this takes you over here as well there's
really not much up here I haven't
figured out what I'm gonna do yet and
these little upper levels like there's
definitely some possibilities but I
can't really think about it right now
because then it's all I'm gonna think
about I think that's I think these are
money trees I didn't mark them I'll
usually mark them I was running out of a
little path designs so I just they know
no more paths for trees more fruit trees
up here I think that's also a money tree
and that's pretty much the whole island
really I'm waiting for another rock to
respawn because they respond one of my
other rocks right in the middle of my
flower patch and if they do it again I'm
gonna lose my mind
Oh mushroom I need to pick up all this
stuff for my Islands I'm gonna maybe
have a last little fossils Bob ask any
friends that they want anything
and then I'm not inventory at all or
sell it so that I can work on that
five-star status because I feel like I
could potentially have any I'm not sure
get that I've been pretty much playing
very just minimally I mean occasionally
asking people here and there on Twitter
for like random items and it's taking a
long time to get stuff and everybody has
all these really cool islands and I have
hours like I think I might be nearing
300 hours and I feel like I've
accomplished nothing
I mean I've done a lot but like I just
feel like I need to do more I need to go
get some cool stuff I need to attend
some catalog parties I've never done
that I just I feel I don't know what I
feel right now what's this gonna be
Oh some clay that's just what just what
I always didn't want I do need to go and
make some of these mushroom DIY is
because they're disgusting I've
accidentally made myself on the southern
hemisphere so right now it's fall
everybody else's islands are thriving
with spring and and I'm over here with
like disgusting mushroom wreaths I just
I hate it like this is so this is
discussing but I have to make it though
I feel like we're back it's nighttime
this is where I want my Ireland to shine
and that's usually where I play it the
most because well actually no I play the
game all day so what am I talking about
I was like why I really want to enjoy my
game when I play at night but I play all
day long but I still want super cool
lights here I love this light I love the
floor lights I even have some lights
over here in a little coffee shop area I
need to get some more of those I will
have some more tomorrow morning when I
wake up I look in the show this is the
view that I like look how pretty it's so
nice and lit up even though I wanted
view more lit up I need more like I need
more lights
I need floor lights I want to have floor
lights all up and down this island I but
I'm getting it's gonna get absurd I'm
dreading harvesting all this fruit
though because I all I wanted to show
you except one of my plants oh gosh I'm
so stressed out
got the orange lights here excited to
see my new bridge tomorrow and then I'm
gonna add it's not a bridge at all it's
an incline and add another incline here
and then I'll start working on that top
area there so cool else need to figure
out a nice little pathway to get to my
house that my friends is a little
nighttime look and the rest of my Island
tour I hope you guys enjoyed it I can't
wait to get some more cool lights really
make this place shine I love this little
ice-cream light it's like the coolest
thing I'm in heaven all right I'll see
you guys later thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video make sure you got
a thumbs up and if you are not
subscribed already please do if you're
new here I make tech videos an
occasional animal crossing videos I
probably would make more of this rock
this is new this was here earlier but I
think was this year earlier I've also
been planting weeds he should not be
here though this is not a good location
for you actually I don't mind it I like
it you can stay although that flowers
been it it's gonna block my that is new
information for today okay I'll see you
guys later I'm still fascinated about
the rock that's me surprise